hey guys Pete peppers here and I'm doing
a walkthrough for level one or two with
some commentary it's a really tricky
level I had a really hard time the first
time I played it so I'm going to try to
talk about some tips the main thing is
we need to make we need to make some
specials and some bombs we set up a set
up a double bond here and that is you
know it one of the first time I ever had
one of those I wondered if it would be a
bad thing because of the fact that it
cleared the bombs on the outside but in
general I don't think it's a real big
deal so you can see here now I'll get my
jam to spread to the middle so that
would that layer that you get to take
off the both sides there I think it's
worth it so if you can set one of those
up do that obviously the best one you
can get is a colouring candy but this is
this is helpful to strike so jelly
leashes what's crazy about this level is
is that you know we have six moves left
here but it's not for sure that we're
going to be able to hit that over there
so you still have to plan things out
pretty heavily here you know there's
nothing the I'm not really worried about
the square that's left in the center
except for would be nice to cover that
up so that if I had a fish I know where
it's going to go you know with a little
bit of
jelly leashes a little bit of planning
you can get it down there and so now the
official would work or I kind of I kind
of messed up there I thought I'd be able
to drop the blue but it made another
match too so now we can use efficient
that'll finish this off with one made so
you know the tips here are really to
take your time and to there's nothing
that you can do in the middle that's
going to really help except for make
bombs I mean you can hit stripes in the
center where they're going to hit the
the blockers directly and stuff but it's
really just a with so few moves
everything you do have to be a setup to
make up a special and it'll take some
tries it's definitely not easy I had to
play it a few times here and you know I
got close a few times so most of the
time you know you just don't even get
anything going so gotta hang in there
make sure that you know those outside
bombs if you have them you know they're
helpful to get the jelly to the inside
but they don't do much else so you don't
necessarily have to set off all four of
them because if you get a bomb in the
middle with a combo it's going to spread
the jelly faster anyway so think about
that and then think about because you
know if you match all four of those
individually that's a lot of your moves
is gone so worried about the layers the
most and then see what you can do
another thing to keep in mind is if it's
when you make fish in the beginning when
it's dry on the inside the fish will
actually go to the blockers but once the
jam spread they'll spread the jam to
other dr square so keep that in mind too
hope this helps you you know you can see
that i made a lot of bombs and i summon
it down for the last move so
just keep practicing to get those things
set up and eventually you'll get it too
thanks